chef kenneth taylor the third of makers
and finders is demonstrating some simple
diy holiday cooking tips for the at-home
chef
and then catherine kelly founder of the
taste buzz food tours is dishing some
black friday entertainment that doesn't
involve shopping
i know that sounds great but first let's
start with you chef what do you got for
us
so there i have some tips just for the
at-home chef uh from my kitchen viewers
um right up here i have some mashed
potatoes i'm just gonna show you how to
quickly do that
it's gonna be super creamy super smooth
and that's going to be using heavy cream
and then tempered butter and all you're
going to do is throw that into the food
processor after your potatoes have been
boiled down and peel
cut them up throw them in slowly mix
everything together turn your food
processor on
add whatever seasons you like and then
just run it until it's smooth
um and then over here we have our dry
brush on turkey
and that's going to be done about four
days in advance you're going to start
falling
and then two days into it right before
turkey day you're going to go through
and you're going to
put a cheesecloth in some melted butter
dip it in there let it sit cover the
turkey completely
and then bake as normal covered up and
then your last about
want to say 30 to 35 minutes of baking
you're going to take off the covering
and then you're going to baste it just
like you would
your normal turkey day turkey and then
another good tip that i can pass down to
you guys is actually going to be
prepping your items in advance whether
it be your cut work for your
stuffing or whether you're doing a
casserole doesn't matter
get that stuff prepped up and cut up one
day before then your day of
while you're doing this throwing it all
in picking it all up and then last up
switching it up with our sweet potato
pie five spice
season instead of doing the pumpkin pie
this year
go ahead oh no i was just admiring i
heard sweet potato pie i got very
excited
but those are really great tips thank
you so much chef now to a great way to
beat crowds in social distance during
black friday weekend
that sounds amazing what are the taste
buds food tours catherine
yes thank you chef those tips are
amazing
um if anybody out there wants to take a
break from the kitchen
or if you're ready just to leave the
cooking up to the pros
you can join us on a taste bus food
tours
we have three here in las vegas uh one
on the las vegas strip we have one
downtown
we have our brand new one in the arts
district food tour where you can visit
chef ken here at makers and finders
we'll take you to try some signature
dishes
at five different foodie locations with
some sightseeing some history it's great
fun it's tons of food for more
information you can visit their website
it's right there on your screen jc